dc is preparing for the u.s freedom
convoy and is being reported by fox that
the national guard will be deployed so
we can expect things to get well maybe
not so much out of hand but a bit more
serious here in the u.s though i think
things will be particularly different up
in canada the police there were
absolutely brutal mocking injuring
protesters and leaked messages gloating
about trampling a woman with horses and
here's where it gets scary
as justin trudeau is using very serious
and extreme emergency powers having his
powers extended by canadian parliament
freezing bank accounts of single mothers
for donating 50 bucks
a new poll has come out trafalgar group
found that 65 percent of likely democrat
voters support
what justin trudeau has done
now i understand it's a different
country but that says a lot about where
democrat voters in this country are now
interestingly in this poll
in unaffiliated voters
overwhelmingly disapproved 74 percent
republican voters i believe it's 87
overwhelmingly disapprove
what is going on in this country
that democrat voters are holding these
extreme authoritarian views and and
supporting
this kind of insanity so i can only i
can only imagine what would happen
with the democrat administration as
these freedom truckers this convoy makes
their way to the u.s so we'll get into
all of that
we have some news as to why that may be
apparently according to another poll
from gallup
democrats don't watch the news right now
they've just totally tuned out more so
than most other groups so that should
that could explain a lot of it cal
rittenhouse is filing or says he's going
to be uh launching a project to file
defamation suits against people who
smeared him like jenkins of the young
turks and whoopi goldberg and then of
course there's um actually very serious
and important news that
biden is sanctioning ukraine specific
abiding and sanctioning russian
officials not over ukraine
and it looks like the north stream two
pipeline may be getting shuttered
because of all of what's happening
look a lot of people don't think there
could be an expansion of conflict over
some regional conflict in europe but
you've got to understand that if the
conflict does
escalate and it has putin's putting
peacekeep peacekeepers military into
eastern ukraine it's just dominoes
falling now biden announces sanctions
then russia says well we're going to do
this that or otherwise then one by one
dominoes fall over on something until
something seriously bad happens so let's
get into all of this
once again talking about just the the
insane state of affairs in this world
and joining us today is the ceo ceo of
fortitude ranch steve renee hey tim good
to be back thanks for coming do you want
to introduce yourself sure i'm the ceo
of fortitude ranch we are a survival and
recreational community we have six
locations across the u.s and we're
looking to continue to expand i'm also
the ceo of survival housing which is a
new startup for us and we're looking to
get into consulting for those who
wouldn't necessarily want to join
fortitude ranch but need some help in
setting up a homestead a preparation a
bug out site we also have uh partners
that we're partnering up with for uh
housing solutions in such occasion so
you've also got military experience
you you actually i think you you're
saying you lived in ukraine as well i
lived in belarus belarus yes visited
ukraine many times so do you think
you'll be able to give us some insights
into what's going on right absolutely
that's gonna be fantastic thanks so uh
thanks for coming we got chris carr
hanging out as well hey the uh one and
only uh executive editor at timcast.com
thanks for having me guys this could be
a great conversation i really look
forward to uh hearing your insights
thanks yeah war is no joke uh world war
one began for much less than what we're
looking at right now it's just a bunch
of defensive packs triggering and no one
really knew what the hell was going on
and all of a sudden everyone's fighting
each other
be ever vigilant if you want to prevent
this stuff
and i am also here in the corner um
steve and his convoy brought me a sour
patch kids little bobble head pop thing
it's amazing i love it and i appreciate
it and i'm really looking forward to
steve because he brings such great depth
of wisdom and he has a lot of experience
in the world so we'll have a great
conversation tonight for sure
they also gave ian a 20 second oh my
gosh i got to show you oh cool yeah
ari brought this for me thanks dude
this is a 20-sided die it's about as
psychedelic as uh as i am 20.
look at this beautiful thing all right
ian roll those 20s tonight before we get
started
head over to timcast.com become a member
if you would like to support our work
our journalists are our staff our field
reporters are all funded thanks to you
as members and as a member you get
access to exclusive members only shows
like the green room where you can see
our guests hanging out in the basement
chilling talking about whatever nonsense
but also episodes of the tim cast irl
podcast that are exclusive for you
monday through thursday around 11 or so
p.m they go live we record them after
the show so that'll be up tonight you
don't want to miss it but don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's get started domestically
because i thought this was a pretty this
is this is pretty big news
fox news reports dc prepares for
possible u.s freedom convoy officials
request national guard troops tow trucks
spotted near washington dc's national
mall now i i found this interesting
because when i was reading all of this
news all of these news outlets are
saying request for national guard
request for national guard and then fox
news seems to bury the lead outright
saying national guard troops will
reportedly deploy beginning tuesday and
remain in place until the end of march
the new york time i'm sorry fox news is
saying they have a source telling them
this
that the truckers are requesting a
permit for 1 000 3 000 people to gather
in the capital and the national guard
will reportedly be deploying tuesday and
remain in place until the end of march
so i don't know exactly what we're going
to see right now tow trucks are
apparently on scene in dc already and
they're saying they've been contracted
by the city for like 10 days or so
and i believe the the u.s freedom
convoys they're set to leave in a couple
days
from barstow california it's barstow
right so we're getting a lot of
conflicting reports i was talking with
our field reporter about that today and
like we're comparing notes and it's
really hard to figure out exactly what's
going on right now but they're expecting
to be in dc what march 1st yes state of
the union
yeah that's the plan that's a bold time
to come in so they're already putting up
security perimeter fencing i think it's
going to look very very different to
what we saw in in canada but i suppose
you know um
the truckers are gonna be prepared for
that and i'm wondering
i saw i'm wondering how things are gonna
go i mean the mandates out here in in
the states i mean they're going away
it's not the same as it is in canada in
canada it's absolutely brutal they're
beating people they're laughing about it
trampled some old old woman you know on
a mobility scooter and then the cops
were posting messages laughing about it
messages got leaked what do you guys
think is going to happen you think the
u.s is going to get rowdy yeah well i
think they're smart to get the permit
first of all right so you don't have a
repeat you don't put yourself in the
same situation what happened in canada
and then uh
but
how
that that doesn't mean that everybody
involved in the convoy you are going to
act the same way
yup so along the way i wouldn't be
surprised if they stop somewhere and
clog something ahead of getting to the
permit site right if you're looking to
make a statement and
so it'll be interesting to see how that
like an fbi agent gets steps up on the
back of the truck and throws a brick and
is like hey the truckers are throwing
bricks i do not this is just red flags
uh red light flashing warning be careful
do not
they're ready for you the fascist
organization that is controlling the
united states and canada and all of the
western democracies this liberal
economic order is ready for you they're
planning for this they're already got
the national guard prepared they're
going to call people domestic terrorists
they're going to put people in solitary
be prepared ian you just cranked it all
the way up to 11. man
first you know the the international
cabal that's controlling the western yes
well uh i i think it's fair to say that
um you know biden called trudeau they
had a conversation about the what's
happening with the convoy biden urged
trudeau to crack down with federal
authority trudeau then
started using these these insane
emergency powers to freeze bank accounts
so i would maybe turn it to 10 just go
down one notch i don't know if there's
some if it's a cabal like biden and
trudeau you know go and then hang out at
a secret meeting underground or anything
like that i certainly think these world
leaders have trade agreements have
economic ties
and whether whether or not you can say
there's one unified organization like as
if biden and trudeau literally work for
the world economic forum i don't know
about all that i know that they're
interested in supporting i know that
they're negotiating with i know they're
attend
they attend these similar events so you
know just one notch down but you know
i'm not completely in complete
disagreement yeah the bank of
international settlements loans money to
the bank of england and the uh federal
reserve of new york which is where i
don't know if canada gets their money
through england i don't know where they
where does canada print its money from
its central bank everyone's just
responding 20.
it's just it's so true when you're up
against a machine gun nest we talked
about this yesterday you do not charge
straight at it that's what these people
have done they charged the position with
the canadian ones the defenders were
like unprepared they're like ah then
they set up a machine gun nest to
protect the area now if you're gonna go
at it you've got to find new
methodologies man it is so dangerous to
repeat this action yeah and and the
other important thing too is with the
freedom convoy in canada they really
undermised underestimated it they they
had no idea they tried smearing it they
tried calling them violent none of it
works none of it sticks so then they
just say okay we go we're going full
fash they just go full fascist they
freeze bank accounts they even get
socialists like vosh posting on twitter
like whoa this has gone too far they
even get you know more establishment
types like steven marsh was on the show
saying like that's martial law so they
went over the top
i'd be willing to bet
they've learned from those mistakes in
the united states very very different
from canada the police are going to be
way more brutal tear gas will be
deployed they're going to be embedded i
guarantee it in the trucker convoy the
moment they leave
following them every step of the way and
i think they're going to do everything
in their power to disrupt it but also
they're going to be spying on everything
the truckers say or do they need more
enemies the january 6 thing's getting
becoming old news and those people have
been off the radar
dude oh god when you have a huge
military you're constantly looking for a
place to use it because it's costing you
money if you're not
well look
we've all we all we all hear about
what's going on in ukraine and with with
russia and it's remarkable that that's
biden's priority i i know it's probably
a cliche at this point to bring it up
it's become a trope the southern border
is wide open just completely uh
obliterated people are pouring through
and the u.s government doesn't care and
so when i see that
you know my my view is it's very obvious
the biden administration has no
allegiance to this country
i just don't believe it i really really
don't sending troops to ukraine why to
help ukraine to help nato to help europe
what about us we don't have troops in
ukraine no we haven't been in belarus or
no we have them in poland poland so the
18th airborne in 82nd and the 82nd are
there yeah now we do have from what i've
read we have troops uh those who are
doing training which generally in the
past that's always been green berets
when they're put into uh that position
that's who generally do the training and
they're trying to help the ukrainian
forces but that's all the way close to
the border with ukraine so we we have no
troops in danger
they're in ukraine i just mean you know
why is it such a heavy priority for the
us to be involved in training in poland
and doing these things when we're not
even taking care of ourselves well
it's really kind of a two-sided coin
i agree right something needs to be done
with the border but that is the plan the
plan is to keep it open right that is
the policy
and so obviously there there isn't any
other way to stop it other than the
states along the border trying to build
their own walls trying to uh enforce
you know what is the actual law along
the border themselves so
i i get the analogy but the danger of
uh what's going on in ukraine right now
is uh one it is immediate i'm not
talking about world war three this has
been a carefully orchestrated plan on
the part of putin and it's not going to
stop even if all he does is what he's
done now he's won
yep i mean he won with crimea no
absolutely yeah and then all he has to
do is take a break and redo it again
and i
you know i tweeted putin was afraid of
trump
and i i believe
i believe it
but i got response um i got a funny
response it was jermaine clement from
flight of flight of the concords
responded to me and he was he said
something like sure he was it was a
picture of like putin sitting next to
trump or something and i'm like i don't
i don't know what that picture is
supposed to be i genuinely believe like
dude putin can walk up to trump and take
a picture with him and smile and laugh
putin wasn't afraid that donald trump
would physically harm him putin's kgb
training you know what does he do jiu
jitsu or whatever i don't think he's
afraid of trump on a physical man-to-man
level like he's going to walk up to him
oh no it's trump he's afraid that trump
is insane
and that if he did something trump would
act irrationally and do something
irrational that would make it very
difficult for him to do exactly what
he's doing right but honestly whoever is
in office and i agree with what you're
saying to a certain degree
no one was going to stop them
okay i don't care who
was in office because we're not going to
put troops in ukraine because they are
not a member of nato yep so we have it's
both sides of defense have agreed right
there's already resolutions already
saying
boots on the ground no
support that's going to happen but
so
i do agree with what you're saying but
we're dealing with a different creature
in vladimir putin but under look so we
saw the escalation of this under obama
and then under trump it kind of just
fizzles it kind of just goes into stasis
biden gets in and all of a sudden it
ignites and ignites again no and true
but that is also part of the cycle and
this is i mean this is kind of what he
waits for right opportunity yeah
so when you have your opportunity you
strike so as we talk about more civil
unrest and civil disobedience here in
the united states listen
china and russia who are becoming closer
and closer together
we have the military capability to stop
either one not both
well i guess the fear is that uh if the
us becomes distracted
china moves in on taiwan or there have
been uh some experts who have argued
that china will adopt the russia
strategy on taiwan and use
pressure control manipulation propaganda
and just slowly eat away at it until
they can take taiwan i feel like the
americans a lot of americans are still
in the mindset of the b-52 the age of
the beef the war of the b-52 bomber like
it's not we're not the dominant force
anymore there's lasers that can blow up
everything from everywhere anyone thinks
that we got the biggest
balls on the planet uh are living in
1970 so
you actually saw trump one time was like
we have the best generals we can win any
and you see the generals like shut up
dude stop don't make us like don't put
us out there as like this this military
but do we really have the best generals
no no we don't we don't and we don't
have the best military either all these
militaries are equally destructive at
this point well
at least the chinese russian and
american militaries if any one of those
wiped the planet clean they could do it
for the 11 aircraft carriers currently
floating around the world we own all of
them but one except how many nuclear
submarines are there that we don't see
to think that we're the best because we
it looks like we're the best it's really
different
i'm a little biased because i served oh
yeah
i think we are the best i not only
and the reason why i think we are the
best now is because we
when i was in
having a patch on your
left shoulder was very rare came from
vietnam
now if you don't have one it's an oddity
we are battle hardened and tested
your these are not just high school kids
just going in and and going through just
training but actually going through the
rigors of war and and i i think it's a
good point ian um we don't know you know
we we can we can only make assumptions
about the capabilities of these other
countries because they're not they're
going to tell us but the same could be
said for the united states so for now if
what we know is we don't know what china
secretly got because it's a secret we
don't know russia secretly because it's
a secret we don't know what the u.s has
because it's a secret as well but the
u.s on top of that has 11 aircraft
carriers out there and doesn't the u.s
have like 20 or something like that well
so the the largest air force in the
world is united states air force and
then the second largest is united states
navy yep yeah air power
and and and i'll just make one more
point sorry
uh
we can see with satellites when other
countries are building weapons
because we can see shipping lanes we can
see the movement of resources i can't
remember who was talking to us about
this they were saying like
you know we would know
if these other countries were building
warships or advanced technology because
of the massive amount of manpower and
resources to move all this stuff when it
came to the manhattan project we didn't
have satellite spot we didn't have spy
satellites or anything like that right
so when blasts were going off you know
sensors were picking things up but the
russians they couldn't you know i'm
sorry this is uh during world war ii
like the you know axis powers were just
like what's happening
throughout the cold war with all the
nuclear testing we it was espionage
you'd like physically go now we got
satellites up there just watching
everybody they can read your license
plates so we can see everything plus we
have ai tracking all the stuff and it'll
be like we've noticed a large deposit of
iron being shipped underground for some
reason and then the us is going to be
like we know something's being built
there well and the key is not simply to
have the best or the well-trained but
you have to have them in position to win
right this is why we don't want to i
mean i i thought larry sharp was you
know that was awesome yesterday great
ideas but to get out of nato
that that would be a mistake
you have to have the force in position
or it's basically
not going to be able to react i think i
want ground forces and now we're in the
age of intercontinental ballistic
missiles and rods from god tungsten rods
dropping from orbit like position we're
all in position now to get destroyed
but that hasn't changed
it's been that way for a long time not
literally since when like not to mention
these or something but we're we're
targeting we're fighting warfare with
sanctions right now so biden's like i'm
going to sanction these rich guys
because they want to put pressure on
these ultra wealthy individuals who are
like hey man i like flying on planes and
eating you know steaks in new york city
don't sanction me and they're hoping
that influence will trickle down and
cause some change i think if we if the
u.s got embroiled it'd be like
the power grid gets blown up um and then
they cut off all their oil from from
europe and asia and no and then
america's
done for like if the power goes i don't
know it feels like so vulnerable
everyone acts so tough and like we do
have great troops and we have we used to
have the best technology but now well
don't get me wrong i'm certainly not
advocating for any of it yeah but i'm
going to defend my brothers in arms also
um
let me ask you guys
if uh the president came out and said we
need to build
wind farms solar power so that we can be
energy uh
we can have sufficient energy in the
event of war
do you think people would be like oh
that sounds good to me or do you think
they'd be like no no war don't do it
raytheon would be like that's a great
idea let's start building solar panels
but
is it isn't isn't that the appropriate
you know you've got the climate change
left right and you've got the energy
independent loving right couldn't they
just be alive we're going to be energy
independent so that no one no one can
screw with us hey the climate change
left wins on this one the right you know
we see the market energy independence we
went on this one where where it seems
like unity there no and there should be
because that's
the grid our electrical grid is one of
the most insecure part of our
infrastructure you know we we have a uh
investor of ours in fortitude ranch his
name is david tyson he's putting out a
documentary on this and it's really
excellent i i was able to get a sneak
peek
and it's uh
griddowndock.com you can actually go and
see the trailer and he's going to be
putting this out phenomenal job he
actually has a booth at the upcoming
cpac um this saturday and so he's
looking to launch that and it was so
well done to show
exactly how vulnerable we are
we have to
i just heard it too a couple news
outlets picked it up not about his
documentary but about this fact because
of the possibility this thing gets out
of hand
are you know that's our weakest point
and when that happens
i'm sorry that's going to bring in uh
this the most serious crisis of our time
in the possible collapse and it'll be a
cyber attack and it will start with
cyber yeah we talked about before the
show we're talking about this and i
mentioned driving down the street and i
saw a big power plant just there i was
like that's the most vulnerable
and then you would mention well that but
that's not even the cyber aspect of it
that's just the physical blunt trauma
you can inflict on the power locally and
think about sleeper cells right
so if somebody's really looking to
destabilize us and things get out of
hand there
that that is going to be uh targeted
yet do you think that that's why because
they're planning on well you got to hold
your horses
that's you're going to enjoy it thanks
tim um
there was this moment during the trump
presidency where trump ordered an air
strike on iranian targets
abruptly donald trump
ordered the airstrike off
told him turn around come back home and
when asked why he said i asked how many
people were down there that said 500 and
i said it didn't make sense to kill that
many people in this strike so we called
it off
but one thing i noticed and it could be
totally unrelated was that
from the point where the airstrike was
deployed
in that moment
i believe it was some kind of oil
refinery in philadelphia exploded for
some reason
now i asked some of a bunch of my
cybersecurity and um you know like
whitehead hacker buddies and they said
they didn't think in any way it was
related and i said is that because you
don't have evidence or because you think
it's impossible and they were like well
i have no reason to believe it sometimes
these accidents happen
but it's certainly possible and so i i
again there's no evidence to suggest
this is the case but is it possible that
trump ordered an air strike and iran
said blow up a reactor and blow up a
refinery in philadelphia did
then they rushed to trump and they said
they're holding our facilities hostage
you need to can't call this off before
we get decimated from a cyber attack
one thing i can tell you is that
industrial control systems in the u.s
are extremely vulnerable to cyber
attacks because a lot of them were built
in the 70s they use this archaic and
ancient operating operating systems
they're they're being updated obviously
and security is a big issue
but man some of the people that i've
talked to who work in the security areas
of this stuff have just been like it's
like a few lines of basic code can blow
up this facility you're making me think
of stuxnet this is from a malicious
computer you've heard of this stuff
malicious computer worm first uncovered
in 2010 and thought to have been
developed since at least 2005. uh it
targets supervisory control and data
acquisition systems and is believed to
be responsible for causing substantial
damage to the nuclear program of iran
now if we did that to iran i'm not i
wouldn't be shocked if iran did that
back and i think it was uh it was the
u.s and israel working together on their
weapon yes and then uh what what it did
was it caused the nuclear centrifuges to
not stop so then they eventually
overheated and blew up
this is just one that we think that
we've uncovered stuxnet there's probably
i think i think it was because someone
found stuxnet infecting like home
computers or something i could be wrong
about that well and so the you know we
got the information from the israelis
the specifics and that's why we knew
exactly how the functioning inner
workings were with the pumps and the
different things that worked the
controlling mechanisms and so we went to
the heart i see so we figured out how it
worked then we wrote code to disrupt how
it worked it was it was specifically
written to do that one thing
it's crazy and and so my understanding
is that
people on their regular computers got
infected with stuxnet but didn't matter
because it has zero effect on your home
computer it was just infecting
everything until it found those specific
you know controls those those machines
for five years until it was all covered
and then it blew up and that was like
wow okay so it's not the only one
there's been a bunch of uh
weapons that have been developed that
have been i think a couple i can't
remember the names and that's years ago
right right yeah it was like 10 years
ago so imagine imagine what's there now
what's out there i went to there's a
conventions there's two of them defcon
and black at the hacker conventions in
las vegas this is 10 years ago mind you
but i i saw these uh hackers
explain very easily how to blow up uh
pump stations they were like you name it
oil water any kind of chemical and they
did a demonstration where they showed
the industrial control system they they
showed it operate and then the guy said
i'm gonna i'm now gonna enter our code
and
activate you know press enter and then
all of a sudden they put a pressure
release valve but what they did was they
told the system to pull to force
pressure in in the same direction so the
pressure collides and built up in one
spot and causes a pipe to explode they
put a pressure release valve on it so
then it sprays across the room and they
catch it a pitcher and water sprays
everywhere
they were like imagine if we if we
didn't have that release valve for the
purpose of the demonstration the pipe
would over pressurize and blow up
another thing they showed us was that
they said for nuclear reactor cooling
systems
there's the computer needs to know the
temperature of the water
they said
only a few lines of code and we changed
the temperature to say it's colder than
it is
overheats it explodes
that's or or melts down you know
disrupts the system if we're wargaming
this a worst case scenario or bad case
scenario there's conflict uh someone
wants to invade the country and then
they blow out the grid the electric grid
with the virus i don't know where to
take up the entire grid is there like a
backup plan and i don't even know if
you're the guy that knows the answers to
this steve but i'm asking you well you
know
it's broken down into segments right so
there's there's four basic
hubs of where this work and how it would
affect it all are not
so intertwined that you could take it
all at once
um
but then you have the whole spectrum of
an emp right if we ever get to that day
which would just completely fry
multiples because if you'd have to do it
at air burst you wouldn't want it to hit
the ground because that wouldn't have
the same effect but doing it as an air
burst then there would really be a
problem i think solar flares can cause
that too yeah to a degree we haven't
seen them you know the magnitude of them
would have to be much more than what we
normally see so let's do this let's
let's start from the beginning of where
we are with this war stuff all right the
story from the daily mail biden
sanctions putin's spy chief his deputy
chief of staff and multi-millionaire
russian military bank ceo president hits
kremlin inner circle and deploys more
troops after slamming russian leader for
thinking he has a right to claim parts
of ukraine so i guess today
that russia kind of upped the ante and
said you know we're gonna you know
occupy the entirety of these regions
even the parts that are controlled by
ukraine because they're saying they're
independent states biden of course comes
out and responds putin i guess what did
he say that he was in a meeting and
didn't bother watching what biden had to
say didn't hear it this is this is the
first domino
sanctions on specific people
if it it it has to escalate beyond this
if we're going to see any any of this
crazy war stuff we've been talking about
so i guess right now if this is what
we're seeing
you know russia is putting troops in
ukraine
do you see it
do you see a strong possibility steve of
it escalating beyond just sanctions yes
because they've already been
claiming that
the
ukraines were shelling the separatists
which there's no proof of that i don't
know if you've seen the articles but
the
the separatists have been shelling
into ukraine that we know for sure we've
seen the sides of kindergarten buildings
with you know the the hole in it so
again we got we have all the propaganda
ganda going on from both sides right but
now you have actual russian troops
that you can say are being shelled and
if actual russian troops are killed and
they blame it on the ukrainians now
we've just tipped another domino it's
amazing right you can invade a country
and then if you get shelled while you're
invading you blame it on the defenders
right exactly that's crazy and look we
you know we have people in the chat who
are saying things like oh but they're
independent regions they have a right to
declare independence
and so the question is did these regions
really declare independence now so
here's where it gets a little bit
sketchy and what i mean is
if you can understand what happened when
the soviet union took over they
russified
all of the occupation countries that
they're in
and so you had generations and
generations that while they understood
their heritage they sort of felt russian
and it wasn't all that bad
and then as the soviet union uh breaks
down and so they retreat back to the
motherland russia proper
you've you've got these generations who
still have a kindred spirit with the
russians and so that's what you're
finding along the eastern border there
with ukraine so the reason they're doing
it this way these are russian speaking
people
this is what they speak every day as you
start getting closer and closer to kiev
as you keep going more to the west they
stop speaking russian and they start
speaking ukrainian well right in kiev
though a lot of people speak both yeah
absolutely so like when i would go to
visit lithuania from belarus
they they so
do not like the russians that it's
offensive to talk to them in russia
but if they didn't know english i had to
fall back on my russian in order for us
to communicate in this progression right
so
but they'd be like ugh i hate to do this
but they would speak russian with me and
and so you get this but that's because
they were ran over right i mean the the
people who are in a bad way now are the
baltic states because
putin has just annexed belarus you don't
i mean there are articles about this but
nobody realized how important that is
the troops are never leaving belarus
again
russian troops in belarus 30 000 that's
how they're going to attack from the
north it would ever happen and this is
actually what puts keeve in such a
a strong very
serious uh
wonderful way you want to know what
really trips out americans i find
it's kaliningrad oh yeah oh yeah
isn't that unbelievable cool but now
that gives let me show you let me show
you uh kalindrad is south of lithuania
and north of poland it's an enclave it's
a yeah it's uh it's it's russia
yes it's a russian enclave piece of
russia right there in the in the baltic
sea and uh so if you're looking at we
got moscow we got russia here we've got
belarus we got latvia estonia lithuania
and then most people don't know this you
show them a map and you ask them hey
look at this right when there's when
it's like there's there's no word here
it's just this little carve out what is
that and the people like it's russia
yeah wait what it's it's russia
kaliningrad and now and and that's very
militarized i mean that's its only real
purpose right and now by staying in
belarus you now give air cover to
kaliningrad this is a fun little factoid
though for americans who don't know
their european geography because i don't
expect americans to for the most part uh
there is a piece of russia
in
just
in between the baltic states yeah this
is kind of what started world war ii
hitler part of germany was split off and
given to poland uh i think was it the su
dayton land i think was that
czechoslovakia part czechoslovakia that
was i couldn't this part of germany was
cut off and given and so he invaded to
take it back like if the russians
invaded lithuania to connect this area
to to russia you would see like similar
to what hitler did well if they're
occupying belarus i mean um what is this
is belarus is very pro-russia
no no so here's the back story to this
their president alexander lukashenko has
been the thorn in the side of putin for
many many years he played he used to
play this game he would go and look
towards the west make him mad but look
for imf money
and then
when he got what he wanted
he would go back to putin
and then he'd give him all kinds of
hassle over that pipeline going coming
through belarus right and they get such
a discount for the fact that that
pipeline goes through there um he he
he literally called him
the fly
on a cat which is like a piece of meat
it's a meat patty in in russian
and he's like you're just a fly on a
piece of meat
but he was a thorn
well
his last election
he could not handle the protests after
it was widespread corruption corruption
everybody knew it they peacefully
demonstrated like they'd never done
before
he couldn't squelch it he called in
russian security forces they helped him
to put down that and his payment now is
they're staying
wow so it's an unofficial annexation
exactly but they are going there is
they're going to uh next month vote to
no longer become neutral which is huge
they have signed a pack saying they
would help the russians fight the
ukrainians never done that before and
everything is changing and now that puts
pressure on the baltics gives air cover
for kaliningrad and then that now gives
you a really quick path down to kiev but
are they i i can't believe russia is
going to move into kiev oh no no i i i
honestly don't think i saw these reports
where they're saying you know it's like
the u.s intelligence agencies are
telling journalists like we believe
russia will occupy kiev and start
hunting down zielinski supporters he's
the president of ukraine and i'm like
that's no way i don't i don't want to
have optimism bias or normalcy bias to
say like the war can't happen but that's
a bit extreme
no honestly yeah it's it but of course
you got to start playing the if it does
happen we we talked about it right so
you got to look good in case it does
right you got to you so they're they're
giving all this
interesting and enough right they're
preemptively trying to say what he's
going to do so it makes you put you in a
better position yo i feel so bad for
ukraine man oh i know uh when when the
euro my dan protests broke out i got
sent there i went to go report there i
was working for advice at the time i met
a lot of really cool people i've a
friend of mine's from kiev and good food
awesome architecture good people i've
really enjoyed my time there and then
you see how the history of this country
is just being brutalized throughout the
soviet union the hall of demore and you
mentioned the russification of the east
it's like well yeah they starved out the
ukrainians
and stole their food and the bread
basket of europe yeah i mean some of the
most fertile farmland absolutely
it's crying shame i mean i would imagine
if he goes past this he needs a land
bridge to crimea that really helps you
so if it's going to no matter how
he what he's looking to do i've heard a
different analysis from different
experts and i agree i i don't remember
who it was but basically taking one
third of ukraine would probably be the
smartest thing to do and wouldn't trip
it into a full uh
third world war you you get the russian
speaking you get your land bridge down
to
crimea and then you're all set for
whatever you want to do now but do you
think he'll go as far as kharkiv
i really don't think so
but honestly you can't
not a very easy person to predict other
than we've seen the pattern over and
over again right of taking some slowly
uh and then backing off so that when you
get to the negotiations this has to stop
and we know from the leaked um emails
through the state department they're
already willing to tell them we won't
put certain military units in certain
areas he's already got um on a defensive
right so it's working i feel like he is
uh actually is easy to predict putin he
seems like a stable military leader like
with secret services like i he's not
going to take too much too fast he knows
that he doesn't want to be seen as a
warmonger i i think i yeah i don't think
that putin's going to be the guy that
gets us into any kind of world conflict
it'll be a response to that if anything
but i don't even well right he's smart
he doesn't want it it would take a
miscalculation i would agree with you
with that assessment
but um
it would take a miscalculation yeah and
that's what that's really what the the
fear is here a miscalculation
fortunately smart and uncontrollable
right a stray missile well i'll tell you
what what freaks me out with uh this
this ukraine uh story with russia uh ian
just mentioned the sudetenland
hitler kept going saying look these
areas were historically german or the
people there are being oppressed and
they're german people so we're going to
move in and what we got from uh from the
uk or from europe neville chamberlain
famously was appeasement right over and
over and over again as this this
psychopath was not only killing tons of
people or had you know it was planning
to uh was
invading other countries and then trying
to just basically take over i would i
would argue as take over the world or
you know claim as much land as possible
we look what vladimir putin's done with
with uh crimea
and now we're looking at what he's doing
with uh the donbass region
if he really does go for a third of the
country he's got to move in further it's
not just going to be the down bass
region and it's a small portion right no
right so you'd go south and you'd go
cut down so yeah yeah yeah you want to
connect those borders so you want to
you want to meet up with belarus there
because now you've already annexed it to
one degree and then you want to go down
and make the connection to crimea i mean
that looks like more like half the
country if he goes from belarus all the
way down to crimea no i'm not i'm just
saying where you have that land bridge
so you just you want to have the ability
then to remove supplies it's about
supply lines right right and and so
you've uh are are we is is joe biden our
neville chamberlain is he's gonna is he
gonna sit back and be like oh you know
look we're gonna what what did he say in
that speech he was like
you know it depends on if it's a minor
incursion right yeah that seemed like a
gaff i don't i don't think that was what
he was in
wasn't was on the list for him to say
it's i think he it's possible it could
have been a signal that you know this
much would be acceptable right i think
it was a gaffe
but i think he said the the quiet part
loud yeah i i think joe biden and you
know the state department they said we
can tolerate a minor incursion we can't
do more than that and biden blurted out
on national tv and putin went really
right okay because it doesn't change
things
to to much of a degree because those
areas were already occupied right they
say they don't have russian troops there
but they have russian mercenaries which
are just
guys straight out of the military going
there i mean special forces all in there
uh
you know you just don't wear the uniform
right just like they did in crimea
so
it it well it does change things because
from what we're talking about is this is
literally an invasion because you're
you're
breaking away international
laws precedences and going across
sovereign border but he already built
the case that that's not true
they asked for independence
we
recognize it and so
but what's the point of it's kind of
silly that putin is like well they're
independent states and they've asked for
help it's like who believes you the
people who already side with you his
people well the russians believe him but
is that really the issue though he's
trying to generate popular support
within russia no but you've got to be
able to say your boldface lie with a
straight face yeah right so you have to
have some argument
that's true i guess if he didn't have
that he'd be telling the people of his
own country we're just trampling over
other countries yeah or but more
importantly the u.n security council
that's where you got to be able but do
they really believe no but it doesn't
matter yeah because he can
he can and in a way it is justified but
so thinking back to the one thing he
really
can truly say is
that nato is really encroaching on his
border right and i mean he can say that
there's truth in that now if you put
yourself in russian shoes you don't want
nato as any closer to you than possibly
they can right
and and so
granted that but to go about it in this
way i mean obviously is
uh the only way he feels he can't
accomplish the buffer that he's looking
for and he's looking for a buffer
you think it's really that i mean with
uh with crimea it's because they have uh
they have the military base there is
that isn't that what the reason was well
yeah well they're just naval base right
so now they have all of what they didn't
have as far as naval infrastructure
and so
and of course listen all you have to do
is pull up
a map of the pipelines leaving russia
and it makes complete sense of
everything that's going on as well i
mean at the end of the day that's what
it's all about ukraine the pipeline's
running through ukraine yeah one of the
biggest so and you have another one
going through
um belarus and like i told you
alexander lukashenko was such a big
thorn now that thorn's gone and at the
end of the day this is the only way he
truly can stay equal with nato it's
through the resources that they're all
dependent on so he has a plan for the
nordstrom deal or else he he wouldn't be
doing this either so crimea is basically
a way to get oil out of
russia yeah well it gives you the porch
but it also gave you now a southern
route of attack
yeah and uh it's it's a phenomenal
position for a world war that crimea and
the baltic is that the baltic sea black
sea black sea oh my gosh what an amazing
that's that's their only warm water port
right right yeah so they they when when
with nato moving in on ukraine and this
is one of the big issues pertaining to
uh the euromaidan movement yanukovych
being ousted
ukraine trying to join nato or align
with the european union whatever it was
russia's thinking we'll lose crimea and
we need that access so they said we're
going to take it now or forever hold our
peace so then a referendum was held in
crimea and they all voted to join russia
oh yeah there you go is that simple i
mean
and that's the thing so if
if zielinski wasn't there we wouldn't be
going through this because he is clearly
pro-west
he is looking to get into nato nato's
not really that interested because they
understand the consequences and
being realistic they understand he does
need a buffer i mean
both sides understand that
but
if if like the former president there in
ukraine if he would have been russian
leaning we'd just we wouldn't be looking
at it wasn't yanukovych russian leading
yes and then he fled to russia after he
got out
so
what people got to understand is um when
we have these conversations it's always
from an american perspective yeah the
russian perspective is more that the u.s
is orchestrating an ousting of
yanukovych to put in pro-western leaders
they do the same thing with syria i'd
say it's probably half true you got it
you got to go absolutely why wouldn't we
well you got to cut through the
propaganda and then figure out what's
really going on and
the the the view of a lot of these
people is that the protests in ukraine
were supported by the west to try and
get rid of a guy who was more favorable
towards russia or at the very least was
kind of playing that game where he was
like what are you going to give me what
are you going to give me you know oh
absolutely we do it all over the world
we've been doing it forever
i mean every side does this it is kind
of funny though that now russia is
playing this game and america you know
joe biden's like how dare you and
putin's probably going like bro
he's like you've been playing this game
well longer than i have yeah you know
now i do it you get mad about it well
yeah we do
i guess so it's it it's tough you know
what what moral uh uh pedestal does the
united states have to stand on when
russia's playing the same game other
than we are powerful and we can tell you
not to do it
no it's a it's very difficult and again
honestly i'm no fan of this current
administration right i mean as an
organization we're apolitical because we
deal with threats we don't deal with
who's causing the threat right there has
to be a realization of that but if
you're looking to analyze this thing you
can't take the past actions
um and allow it
to warp you to not see something for
what it is so i agree the whole thing
about the border but it really doesn't
have anything to do with the truth of
why we shouldn't not uh
not be in nato and why there isn't a
reason for us to at least be making sure
that this doesn't spread i think you
made a great point though the southern
border board the southern border policy
is to be is to be weak that is it yeah
so by design so when people are coming
out and they're being like why why
aren't we defending our own borders like
well it's that's the opposite of what
they want right they absolutely don't
want it right that's a proven fact now
yeah
well that just says to me that i think
you know ian's talking about this this
global what do you call it like liberal
economic order liberal economic order i
guess some people call the davos group
or the great reset or that kind of
reform 1946 is when they formed the
liberal economic order right after world
war ii when you have when you have an
administration
that uh
tells canada you know by administration
hey use emergency powers crack down to
an extreme degree and they do when you
have an administration that says our
policy is for the southern u.s border to
be just completely open
and then we're going to go defend and
worry about russia and ukraine yeah it
just sends a hard signal i understand
why we care you know we don't want just
you know things firing out of control
but it certainly just seems like biden's
priority is not america no right so it's
frustrating right but i guess you know
i guess i would just say don't become so
jaded that you don't you simply because
you don't like what's going on in the
border you don't realize the importance
of ukraine that's all i'm saying keep it
keep keep one separate from the other
because they are two separate things and
while one may really frustrate you and
don't underestimate the importance of
what's going on there i i wonder though
just you know one last thought on all of
this you know
what's the probability you think this
could spiral into a greater conflict
beyond just the small this region
the possibility definitely exists i
don't think that would be the plan in
the immediate um
but
i don't think it's ever the plan right
well i the plan is you know it has been
take crimea subjugate belarus get
portions of ukraine he's clearly had
this plan been working on it for a
little while it's all coming to fruition
because there is
no uh
there is really nothing we can do but to
try to keep it from spiraling right
if he wants it he can take it that no
one would no one's saying otherwise the
ukrainian forces cannot stop the initial
assault now they can become partisans
and turn this into a guerrilla type
warfare true
and that's more probably what he doesn't
want than anything he wants to topple
this government though he wants
zielinski out and he'll do that by any
means and the fact is where does the
calculate has he calculated right or
hasn't he i'll say you know that i see i
see two potentials when we look back at
what germany did with you know as again
to reference what he inside the sudan
lands and uh the appeasement
that that was only the war that broke
out was one potential of what what could
have happened and we look back on
history and we say look at what germany
did it led to war therefore these things
lead to war it's not necessarily true
that time it did in this instance we
could sit back and just appease and try
and placate come out and say peace in
our time whatever nonsense and and maybe
vladimir putin will take the don best
region and just stop
there's no guarantee that actually turns
into world war three but i will add it
is it is a a variable that could lead to
that point it is it is a moment in time
that could lead to a very similar
circumstance it's hard to know if it
will though and what do you do do we as
americans say
we can't allow russia to they they've
they've used this strategy over and over
again i guess they used it in what was
georgia they played this game they do
with crimea if we sit back and it's five
ten years later and now a third of
ukraine is under is under russian
control as a satellite state
do we just let that keep happening until
the baltic states you know are now just
under the boot of russia do we intervene
what happens if we don't what happens if
lithuania belarus or i need these other
countries poland loses their mind saying
like we are not going to allow that
because they certainly don't like what
the soviet union was all about
what happens if that just breaks out
into a war in europe we stay out of it
saying we don't want to be involved
china moves on taiwan now there's
fighting in the pacific there's fighting
in eastern europe the u.s begins doing
weapons deals with european countries
and then china says you are funding our
enemies and then bombs pearl harbor
oh
yeah we could talk for a long time on
how far could you guess it would be the
same playoffs oh absolutely and
the you know what they would say
they would they we talk we talk about
how uh between world war one and world
war ii it was one war with a 20-year
armistice or something like that that
was just reignited from the same
grievances
you could argue that this is a remnant
of the same of the end of world war ii
the difference would be china wouldn't
bomb pearl harbor although they might
they would bomb san francisco new york
washington dc
uh dallas
fort worth they would buy um kansas city
they'd bomb seattle they all at once it
would all happen in a day in in an hour
i use bombing of pearl harbor not in a
literal sense but to make a point to be
clear right the similarities between
world war ii and what we're seeing here
uh i'm not so sure china how many nukes
do they have like 50 they don't have
money do they no they they they got
plenty
plenty enough you only need one right
well right nuclear submarines off the
west coast there's the most dangerous
part right russia has got more than they
could possibly use
same thing with us you know i was in
nukes for five years we had 12 rush i
was stationed in germany we had 12
nuclear uh missiles pointed at russia 24
7. wow
12 that you knew of
yeah that so what we did was we rotated
we rotated one battalion does it for 30
days because it's around the clock if
you're in the shower and the alarm goes
off you have 30 seconds to make it to
the gate and get those missiles launched
because our life expectancy was 30
seconds what what what year was this so
that would have been 89 these were
pershing two missiles
so they were short range could hit they
come within 10 meters of their target
and you're talking about a nuke
you don't have to come that close right
but but it was low yield they'll blow up
in the air no these were made to hit
targets interesting yeah and so
now we on salt 2 treaty we did away with
them and that was for to
everybody to back down right because
we're getting towards the end of the
cold war
let's not have so many of these just
sitting there active ready to go
and and so those were done away with
that's when i so my basically my mos was
no longer and that's when i switched it
to the military
was it was it under trump the start
treaty basically fell apart yeah
denuclearization started to
well it's because everybody else never
follows it right i mean russia breaks it
all the time iran's broken it all the
time that's what gets so frustrating
although you have to sit down at the
table you have to do it
but it it never really solves i think
weapons
look with the manhattan project you had
this decentralization the
compartmentalization people didn't know
what was being what was being done until
after a bunch of bombs fell and also
everyone figured out what america had
done and uh the decades after that
the the nuclear weapons um we have today
are about uh one thousand to uh one
thousand twenty one thousand to one
thousand two hundred and fifty times
more powerful than the bombs we used in
world war ii and that's something yeah
one icbm
a merv a multiple independently targeted
reentry vehicle carrying 10 to 12
warheads peppers the eastern seaboard
you don't need 50 nukes no you don't you
need 10 warheads in one icbm and then it
goes up into the stratosphere and this
goes
and they all just go up
wipe out cities and i mean these things
are massively powerful not to mention
the latest developments and this is i
think this was actually like seven years
ago i was researching this in gravity
bomb technology which is the bombs we
used in world war ii are gravity bombs
we drop them from planes
we don't launch them anything we've
compressed those down really really
small megaton bombs so they're they're
very small
and and comparably is powerful
the weapons that we know about scary i
mean think about nuclear artillery oh
yeah i mean
i haven't looked into it but how how
what are the actual artillery pieces
that can launch nukes no put what load
of warhead and howitzer you're right i
mean there's a there's different
versions of what can do what but
just
the idea that these types of
capabilities exist is
why we don't use them okay because in
the end
nobody wants to really blow up the
planet right so it's been a it has
worked in deterring
it's not going to stop everything but it
has worked in deterring
i guess it partly makes me think like
why if china invades taiwan no one is
going to try and stop it if russia takes
crimea or belarus no one's going to stop
it if america takes mexico no one's
going to stop it because no one wants
well these conquering empires to fire
their nukes taiwan is very sensitive
because they make 63 percent of all the
chips that we are already short of
63
if i'm accurate
that's huge
is it the kind of thing where like it's
better that no one has it than china has
it well
if they dominate that market right we so
you see the pictures of i saw one this
week where ford broncos are piling up in
the parking lot again because
uh the shortage of chips
and that's because we don't produce them
here which we're trying to rectify right
there's a lot of things we're trying to
rectify because we've seen our our
weakness through covid and how much
control china has over these things add
in taiwan to that
and it just
it would [ __ ] technology yeah so yeah
it's very important we would do
something but is it the kind of thing
where we would like scorched earth the
place and be like hey you can't take
this from us you can have you can have
nothing and none of us get it well we
would i would imagine we would literally
actively try to stop them right and
that's going to have to do with our
naval power because
you know we
that's where you you send the seven
fleets right if
because that's where we're gonna have to
start because that china has slowly been
building those islands
to claim that entire region but also to
give them a place to launch something
militarily building islands is a smart
move very smart and so that means you
know the marines would have a tough job
yeah that's what they'd have to clear
they'd surround taiwan and blockade the
island i would imagine the chinese yeah
so you think there'd be like c battles
right no there'd be a air foot right in
here on the sea because we don't have
troops on the ground yeah if china and
the united states ever
fight each other that's like the
beginning of total war
i think limited war is when like the
taiwanese forces are fighting the the
belarusian forces and they're both
funded by
one side or the other americans are
funding the taiwanese and the chinese
are funding yeah so fortunately the
right for us there's a great distance
between us and china us in russia other
than alaska
right because all you have there is the
baron sea but uh
i mean that's what's kept the peace
right and and that's been our that's
been our beauty
we've had
canada and we've had mexico there's no
threat there right militarily we have a
sweet spot right here so it's not easy
for to get to us
therefore we have to project power
that's why we make our navy what it is
and and that helps us to control the
situation until you can actually then
get the rest of what's needed boots on
the ground the supplies that go into all
that and again that's why
not being a part of nato would would not
be smart i'm gonna i wanna make another
point too is you know especially as
we're talking about nuclear weapons
america is is is
the united states great geography in
terms of war just because we we've got
both coasts we've got the interstate
highway system which the mountains
are grounds seriously and then i was
thinking about you know but what if you
know we're talking about nuclear weapons
you know ian you were mentioning china
we just wipe out all these cities i tell
you this
even if
the u.s got nuked to kingdom come by you
know dozens of warheads they would still
not be able no one would be able to
conquer this this country for one reason
the sheer amount of guns that exist here
even after we've been nuked yang coming
in although and i'm thinking about that
video game fallout which i love fallout
3. and i'm imagining like
in this game in the fallout series
you're finding guns and bullets
everywhere and i'm like actually it
makes sense but what if the game took
place in china or in australia that
you'd find none
so thinking about that if a nuclear war
really broke out you know there's a
there's a quote from einstein i know not
what world war three what i know not
what weapons world war three will be
fought with but world war four will be
thought fought with sticks and stones
and i'm like
no i i don't know i think world war iv
would just be the united states armed to
the teeth with all of the insane amount
of guns they have and then they would
just conquer everybody i don't know it's
not the disease that i'm concerned like
the native americans 95 of them were
wiped out by smallpox when the settlers
came over numbers i've heard i could see
like nuclear war and then just disease
cause it kills the all these people with
their guns that just starve and run out
of water and then get sick and die and
then someone comes in to clean it up so
we're strong enough now right
but we used to live in the united states
of america we now live in the divided
states of america
and herein will be our achilles heel
because politically
and culturally there does not seem to be
a path
back to
normalcy
where we could get five individuals
six into this room and speak like
rational adults
right the conversation is no longer
happening
and
i don't i don't know how we turn that
corner
because it
it's just we just seen it with canada we
would never would have guessed right
that it would have gone to that extreme
and
report the problem is
now this is happening at the level of
our children because of the foolishness
in schools
and listen i i
you know i sort of understand the
argument but let me make one thing
personally clear
no one on the face of the planet is
going to make me feel guilty for being
born
right
so i did not choose where when and to
whom i had nothing nothing to say in
that matter but people on the other side
of this politically and culturally are
not going to understand that language
that you're speaking you know the
languages are so different so you
juxtapose at this point like you really
can't communicate that's why that's
normal divide and i get that believe me
so i'm not going to go out and try to do
no harm to anybody else but
they will no one will make me feel
guilty for being me but what happens
when they show up to your neighborhood
with guns
what happens when they're marching
through your streets arm telling you you
can't drive your car through here
anymore and they point rifles at you so
this is the problem this is what we're
seeing up in portland
and it just culminated in a very serious
incident over the weekend where a guy is
critically injured four uh four others i
think uh three other uh so there's a
total of five people were shot one died
the uh the guy in conflict with antifa
was critically injured and three other
antifa were were seriously injured put
in the hospital i believe they were
arrested in the er
you know we had um i know i've been
mentioning it quite a bit in the past
few episodes but i think it's important
we had stephen marsh he wrote this book
it's a wave it up there on the wall uh
the next civil war
he said this country is a multicultural
democracy and a constitutional republic
inside at the same time and they can't
coexist
he's he he said you know you mentioned
just now how do we turn that corner he
said when will you something effective
when will you realize you in this
country like what's happening
my view is you know what i told him was
as a canadian you love your socialized
healthcare okay you give that up you
abolish that we go private we have peace
and he said point taken
based on what you are saying about
people making you feel guilty for for
being born
when if someone comes up to me these
these uh democrats out of california
they wanted to repeal the civil rights
language from their constitution the
language that says you cannot
discriminate on the basis of race gender
identity etc they said we want that gone
we want that right i say no
no compromise
so how do we don't so anyway to kind of
bring this back to where we were with
war and nuclear weapons and stuff i
think our achilles heel is exactly the
right point
when uh jesse kelly today
he's a funny guy he tweeted that um i
mean seriously but he made a good point
he said we need a national divorce
because um
democrat voters are polled showing they
support what trudeau was doing with this
authoritarianism
and the scary thing is i don't think
he's wrong
but i think if he's right and we do have
a national divorce
russia walks all over eastern europe
takes what it wants china takes taiwan
they both expand exponentially
and that's it we now as americans live
under heavy trade restrictions and under
the boot of these uh
mostly china
it wouldn't be the united states
necessarily because who knows what would
happen to this country but it's not just
going to be fighting here it's going to
be us
being subjugated by oppressive forces
from china from the communist party from
their allies from russia when it comes
to trade especially no without a doubt
and that again that's why our strength
right we've lost our strength by
not being the united states of america
and
i mean this is why fortitude ranch
exists
this is why we're trying to have 12
ranches across the country so that
hopefully you wouldn't have to drive any
more than one gas tank
but you've played fallout oh yeah video
game how amazing would it be that if in
the real world they weren't vaults they
were fortitude ranches
and there's there's six you know there's
500 of them or whatever you guys become
this major conglomerate corporation
everybody lines up you do these
uh spiffy 50s style tv ads come sign up
for fortitude
you know you got to go somewhere when
the bombs drop right yeah come on down
as funny as that is that'd be great on
the game you're working on right working
fortitude tokens instead of uh caps
bottle caps yeah instead of bottle caps
right
but you guys should have a bunch of
bottle caps that'd be funny yeah that
really
is a bit i know when you when people
show up to sign up for the ranch be like
here's what we used to trade
see how many of them get the reference i
know i wonder if they would i mean
considering they're familiar with you
know survival camps or fortitude they
might understand the joke yeah and you
know our membership um has has changed
over the years it used to be more of the
along the hardcore prepper type
uh but once covid hit
uh things started to change but once
civil unrest hit that changed everything
people uh
man
they take everything for granted
absolutely
the normalcy bias is what really really
gets me the optimism bias and the
normalcy bias optimism meaning that
people think bad things won't happen and
normalcy they think things can't change
but boy can they change and they can
change fast
i mean that's why i point out this the
first civil war in the united states
nobody thought it was gonna happen
because everybody just thinks world war
one two that just happened so fast all
of a sudden one day it was the world was
a piece the next day
we got a guy got assassinated and we try
to be rational about it right last time
i was on it was about a year ago you
asked me what you thought the percentage
was of you know seeing some real
violence as we turned the corner of the
election i said five percent and you're
kind of surprised um that i would say
five percent but as you saw see the
things weren't in place was it because i
thought it would be higher or lower
higher i thought it'd be higher yeah and
the
especially right because i'm the
fortitude ranch guys so it would seem
like you've got an economic incentive to
tell everybody 100 exactly exactly
right so we don't play the fear game i
mean that's not what that what it's
about right
and and again so we as an organization
we stay political so that we could
really try to have the right data we
never activated for kovid we did
activate and that's how you actually
invited me to the show for the election
and that was a given opportunity for all
the new members basically to come bring
their supplies and get to know him right
it was basically uh let's sit and watch
the elections kind of get together we
really weren't
thinking that it was going to be and
that's another reason why you thought it
would probably be higher because we
activated it for the first time in
existence but i also had i think you
guys got to activate this november
oh well so now here's the thing right we
haven't even gotten into that
so there's no path it seems like going
forward and now things are going to get
loonier
you thought trump point one was
something wait for trump point two let
me let me pull up this story which can
kick off this bigger conversation on the
conflict in the u.s because this is
actually kind of
weird it's tragic it's creepy it's weird
we have this from opb alleged killer in
portland's normandale park protest
shooting has been identified they're
saying it's a man named benjamin jeffrey
smith he's being identified as a local
furry
that antifa claims is a nazi because
furries have a known nazi problem
it's very very strange that this is the
story that's coming out but uh just in
reference to this this this story
the um they flat out say
smith's identity was first reported by
anti-fascist researchers
and the oregon oregonian organ live sm
and the oregon live news outlet
the information we're getting about the
shooting is coming from extremists
how can you trust it of course they're
taking quotes from me and they're
screaming that i'm lying and all the
stuff and andy no is lying i i don't
care what these you know twitter antifa
people think because i think they're
psychotic despotic
fascist extremists
when they say that about me i know
they're lying because i know they don't
really believe that we we do a show like
if you look at all the online forums
they refer to me as a libertarian
centrist you know i flat out say leave
me alone i want to i want to have
nothing to do i get away from the cities
there's no way these people who are in
portland who are going around with guns
pointing at pointing at people
threatening people smashing property
genuinely believe
the people running away are the fascists
there's there's no way they know they're
lying they know that so i don't care
what they think but this is the the
nature of of the escalation we've seen
so we had you on just before the
election
in 2020 because uh
fortitude ranch
activated and there was a bunch of
stories coming out saying like you know
survival camp activates warns their
their members or whatever this potential
for violence you said it was around five
percent
when i talk to people they have such a
normalcy or optimism bias it can't
happen here
i know i i don't know how
you know to explain to the people who
don't want to believe it maybe there are
people who just don't want to hear it
it's not about they don't believe it
they do believe it but they're just like
please no please no go away if i close
my eyes and ch you know cover my ears
close my eyes it'll just stop it'll stop
you know
but it's coming and i think people need
to pay attention to this because we're
at the point now where
there's a group of antifa marching to
the street armed
telling people where they can and can't
drive
in the past not even that long ago
a guy was in his truck and they
threatened him and he pulled a gun so
they pulled him out of his truck and
they beat him
we've seen aaron danielson in portland
he was shot
shot twice in the chest and killed
then bill barr's doj hunted down this
guy michael reinel and they say he got
into a [ __ ] with him they killed him
these antifa people view that as trump's
administration the maga right the
populists
engaging in retribution to me it does
sound a lot like retribution it doesn't
matter though it doesn't matter which
side you're on it doesn't matter if you
think you're right it's just at a
certain point you need to wake up to
realize this stuff is happening it's
happening with increasing frequency
and you know so so to escalate this to
where we're going now that the elections
are coming up midterms
the democrats lose power in in the house
and
in the senate then republicans are going
to go off the wall i don't believe most
republicans will go off the wall i
believe the trump maga america first
types are going to be like
revenge and retribution and if people go
out and vote in the primaries and get in
real politicians not establishment crony
bad idea or no idea republicans i guess
rhinos
if if actual new incumbents come in i'm
sorry new candidates wipe out push out
the incumbents we might actually see
some real action from the republican
party
but then you're going to see antifa
losing their minds
then you're going to be getting into
2023 which is the presidential primary
season with donald trump coming out
saying we will win
antifa is going to go crazy and then you
have 2024 an election year and then
donald trump wins so then what happens
trump 2.0
madness
madness so what i'm wondering is is what
level can you take it to next because it
was already an existential threat right
aliens so where else do you go and i
mentioned this before we started going
on air right maybe that's when we see
the aliens come in and calm all this
down because
honestly i don't know where you can go
other than more
of the i mean i'm speaking verbage right
because the way they explained it last
time
and and interestingly enough
putin even used that word uh as he
explained what was going on
uh existential threat accidental threat
yes and he used that word it's
interesting how it always right gets
picked up and passed around and used in
so many circumstances uh right it
becomes the the phrase of the day but
so i just don't know how
how much more nuttier or how the
language can get any more over the top
then
they'll find a way right because
they truly believe
that it's the worst possible thing that
can happen i remember you know back when
he was elected
and
uh
the girlfriend i was that i was with at
the time
and
she lost her mind i said listen
you know how many presidents
administrations i've lived through so
far in my lifetime
they come and they go they come and they
go and the world doesn't end it's
everybody who doesn't come and go in
washington that we're really going to
try to do something about the
administrative state man they need term
limits yes and and then
every
people if you know
i get it it's so important to you if you
haven't lived through a bunch of these
but when i was in school i was literally
taught the next thing coming our way was
an ice age yeah
that's what i was taught as a kid i
believed it
i thought the next great thing that
happened to mankind was an ice age and
i've lived through all the others of
about this there's a great video um i
don't have a po i don't know if i could
pull it up but i think it's carl sagan
talking about the um the the global
cooling
and he's like scientists believe a great
ice age could be coming
and it was like from the 70s you know
and then science changes right
absolutely you know people panic for a
lot of different reasons
i think the issue we're facing now is
there was a point at which
american society hard forked
split into two distinct entities
for a while they were close enough
together where was an argument saying
like what are you doing over there we're
talking over here now it's so far
divided
it's just i think i figured out we're
young across the chasm i was thinking
about thinking about a lot about this
there's there's multiple ways to think
and to problem solve and to come to
conclusions one of them is the
scientific way to do it which is you
acquire evidence over time and that once
you get enough evidence you can
confidently say this is what i believe
is happening then there's warfare where
you have no information about what the
hell is happening you know that there's
artillery firing from over there there's
a machine nest now you have to make a
decision and people are in the war mine
state they're afraid they're terrified
probably by design so they're making
these split-second decisions without
information and acting like
these are supposed these are like solid
scientific
ways to to look at things and they're
not you're you're half i think you're
half right i think they're lacking
information i think they're in a war
mind but i think it's by choice
we have the story from axios democrats
tune out national news during biden era
look at this democrats just spiked
straight down this is exactly the
problem i've talked about with you know
the obama activists the i'm sorry the
anti-war activist voting for obama the
moment their guy gets in they turn off
so now what's happening is democrats are
no longer paying attention to news
they're now below republicans but
they're still acting on politics they're
still engaging in conflicts they're
still pushing and and they're they're
still active
they're just willfully ignorant now i
think what like what you said man people
feel like this this is gonna
there's too much emphasis being placed
on the political candidate it's to be
afraid
or
to have total faith that your
candidate's gonna solve save the
situation is ridiculous we found that
out with obama turning his back on
people and to think that this candidate
is going to destroy the world is also
ridiculous the system's built around i
mean i understand an executive can be
kind of crazy and can do stupid stuff
but we have plenty of safeguards no
exactly and and
so we're we're definitely going to see
right so if everything seems to play out
the way it looks because of the
overreach in some of the ridiculousness
of how covet has been handled
you you probably see you know the
democrats getting a good shellacking in
the midterms right
now the backpedaling is starting they
understand they're they're
losing the independence the people are
really getting sick and tired of this so
this is going to unravel to a certain
degree then like tim said so that just
brings about
blm and antifa now being in the streets
more than what we've seen them over this
past time it intensifies and intensifies
and then who knows it should come to
some kind of crescendo for you know 2024
in the presidential elections well
you're familiar with uh strass how
generational theory right yeah so um
by 2028 should be the end of the fourth
turning
so uh don't be surprised if i i believe
we
you know we're in it for around what 20
years or so yeah is when it starts
kicking into high gear and surprise
surprise that's 2008.
the start of this economic crisis which
escalates dramatically causes look i
think the economic crisis really is a
big
uh precursor to everything we're seeing
you get a young generation who can't get
find jobs
uh people my age getting out of college
all of a sudden
unable to work as dishwashers something
i experienced i remember i went to a
small tiny hole in the wall diner and
there was a guy in his suit applying to
be a dishwasher for 10 bucks an hour and
i'm like some scraggly dude and a beanie
like how's just looking for some side
cash man this guy needs it more than i
do
you get these young people who then say
why is my life so bad and they blame the
one percent
this drives them into this this quest
for meaning
unable to do work unable to pursue their
passions
that escalates over 10 years with them
getting into activism turning news into
activism putting politics in every
corner of every aspect of our lives and
now we're at this point today
uh so eight years after the crisis you
get donald trump donald trump being a
symptom people are saying we're tired of
this we want something to change the
other side believing trump was a fascist
and literally hitler going insane
all of that has continued to escalate i
think occupy wall street you get the
financial crisis which leads us to
occupy wall street which brings this
critical race theory activism into the
fray with all the activists in new york
who then engage in violent tactics black
block tactics it escalates
i suppose you could even go back further
than that and figure out where all this
stuff started when they you know uh was
a glass-steagall gets repealed or
whatever and then how this all begins
but i think the big spark like something
broke 2008
then what 2020 the end of this period of
strife a hard time
which is economic crisis which is
political crisis which is street
violence
the night is always darkest for the dawn
but uh 2024
i think is going to be bad i think this
year is going to get bad already the
activism is getting nuts this story is
crazy i think 2023 is gonna get bad i
think 2024 will be worse because trump
will end up as the republican nominee
what's what are the democrats going to
do biden i have no idea
2025 donald trump is inaugurated what do
you think january 20th 2025 is going to
look like in dc you think january 6 is
bad wait till january 20th 2025 for the
second inauguration of donald i got to
say
i think there's no way trump is going to
even have a chance at being president
i'll go on record now i could be totally
wrong maybe i'll eat my words i didn't
think he was gonna win last time either
with hillary clinton uh i was shocked
but i it's like the same kind of
surprise attack thing in military you
don't do it twice they they're ready for
it now it's gonna be total media uh what
do they call what the time magazine
article call it shadow campaign
fortification yeah the total media
fortification of uh their candidate but
i think that's a key factor here over
the past six years the corporate press
has lost a lot of credibility right even
with normies they have for sure oh yeah
you've always kind of been dialed into
it i'm wondering if like the average
person well it seems like even the
democrats are kind of tuning out are
they going to crank that crank up their
viewing again when it looks like trump
is going to win a second term or has the
corporate press actually lost some of
the credibility that you used to have i
don't know i i've seen it seems to me
like it's crumbled quite a bit well it's
going to really hinge on who's going to
be the candidate also democratically
right
i mean well let me yeah
that's going to be andrew yeah crazy
trump will win prospect so that's that's
going to be huge i want to pull up this
story uh this is from the daily wire
majority of democrats back trudeau's
crackdown freezing bank account of
truckers there's something really
important here ian was just saying that
he doesn't think donald trump could win
the presidency because they're going to
be ready for him right
yeah
so uh
using the same strategy twice the
previous context for those that may have
missed it we're talking about the
freedom convoy in canada we're talking
about how trudeau cracks down then the
u.s is playing this convoy and ian you
are saying that they're going to be
ready for the us truckers
so they can't use the same strategy
they're going to be ready for donald
trump he can't use the same strategy but
there's one thing that i think does that
you may overlook in this in this regard
what if
instead of you know a thousand or 500
trucks coming to dc like in canada it
was 50 000.
now it was reported there was 50 000
truckers protesting i don't think there
was that many trucks i think that's
probably misreported but let's say that
dc does plan for this and they say
we're going to handle it
500 trucks no problem but then 50 000
trucks from every angle come in you
can't handle that there's no planning
for that that would be a different uh a
different plan so let me show you this
in the story about democrat support for
trudeau they say
the the poll shows 55 of general
election voters disapprove of trudeau's
handling of the protesters 35 approved
that is to say the majority of people
don't like the the draconian powers take
a look at this
democrats 65 percent approval
republicans 87
disapproval
and independence 74 disapproval that is
to say
republicans say no to trudeau
unaffiliated voters say no to to trudeau
it is only the democrat base that about
two-thirds support what trudeau is doing
with these draconian powers
this this these metrics are reflected in
basically everything when we pull up
civics polling data is the economy good
independent voters two to one say no
republicans
ten to one say no
democrats two to one say it's great
now how is that possible it's an
inversion the fact is
independent voters and republicans the
plurality of the majority of people in
this country do not live in the crackpot
cult reality that the democrats live in
so if donald trump does run again they
can plan any shadow campaign or whatever
fortification they want but when 10
times many people are storming through
the gates no amount of planning will
stop that man yeah the independence
there is really important because that's
your proxy right i mean those are the
people that aren't really affiliated i
mean if if they're siding with
republicans i mean not even siding with
them but if that's the way they're
perceiving reality right but but this is
all these represent the chasm right the
chasm that we're talking about it's we
kind of forked at a certain point
culturally in this country and the chasm
is just so great you might try to holler
at somebody way over there it's just
like what's the point i mean they're not
even going to understand the language
that i'm speaking right now
you know that's scary but but to your
point like
i don't know how we're going to remedy
that cultural problem that we're
experiencing the chasm's just too wide i
think that that's that's making me think
of that mentality that combat mentality
versus the scientific mentality and so
many people are in combat mentality that
if you try and speak to them
scientifically with like facts and
evidence they don't get it it's too big
of a deal for them to think about they
got to act now this is it's like life or
death to these people so if you can
understand that before you start
communicating with them and
for them it's a big deal maybe for you
it's not i mean obviously i'm not
freaked out by this stuff but
if you understand there it's same with
saying talking with a kid too if you
understand why something's such a big
deal to them it's a lot easier to
communicate with them about it
yeah rapport building is is the first
strategy in in persuasion yes so if you
approach someone as an enemy or as an
other
they are less likely to trust you they
fear you
so if you're trying to actively build
bridges in the political conflict you
have to approach
your political enemies or your political
rivals
as one of them it's a very difficult
thing to do
i i i gotta throw it to uh daryl davis
though and say i think we're beyond that
unfortunately you can certainly try i'm
not saying never you know give up
but that story about daryl davis he's
the guy who de-radicalized those clamor
the black jazz musician de-radicalizes
clan members but when he tried to talk
with antifa outside of the event we
booked him for they wouldn't talk to him
yeah he directly confronted the mob and
that's that's a hard that's a big ask
i've never successfully confronted a mob
and come out at the winner but confront
maybe is the wrong word he just said
addressed themselves i want to talk to
them yeah he walked across the street
and they started yelling at him and they
called him a nazi and other you know
white supremacist and he was like just
want to talk guys and they wouldn't do
it something similar might have happened
though if he was trying to address like
a clan rally no he's done that he's done
but it started at the individual level
right it was just like one guy and then
another show up to clan rallies he went
to clan rallies and walked up to people
and talked to them
and he posted about how
never he never experienced what he did
with antifa when he when when he went to
clan rallies they were like what's this
guy doing here and he said you know he
started talking to people and they
started talking with him and they told
him all of their racist ideas and he
said okay
just wondering what you were thinking
and then after a long enough period of
time they realized they were wrong
and their racist ideas weren't correct
with antifa he walks up and they scream
at him they won't even let him talk yeah
they want to fight they're there to
fight so it's a more poisonous ideology
than racism even
oh i certainly think so
i think the issue with racism is that
it's it's it's
incorrect
and can lead people towards dangerous
policy and violence
the far-left extremism is inherently on
step one of the hopscotch is be extreme
and destroy
racism is you you don't like people for
stupid reasons it escalates from there
antifun the far left starts with violent
revolution i hate that burn it all down
mental it's so stupid like it why would
you ever destroy what we've created
before you have a new thing to do what
the
it's a 12 year old's mentality yeah it's
so very short-sighted immature right so
it's extremely immature yeah and it's
extremely
you know short-sighted and
so now
you know like i said no one's going to
make me feel guilty for being born i
wouldn't chose
my parents love them um take take a take
a bunch of ten-year-olds
take 30 10 year olds and put them in
charge of an office building see what
happens
this is this is what's happening right
now good times make weak men we're in
the fourth turning we're in the period
of weak men who have made hard times
although i'm thinking now figuratively
because women are involved i'm thinking
scorched earth now because that's a
military tactic so if these people
really are in combat mind state
then the scorched earth tactic is on the
table like if someone's invading your
city and you can't defend it properly
you burn the entire city to the ground
and retreat so that when they get there
they don't have a city to pillage and so
maybe that's what these people are doing
i think you know what you see within
that thought through that far to tell
you
there there is a um
it's a rudimentary
plan it's there
anti-fun portland
they everything they do
serves their purpose their goal right
if they go out in the streets with guns
and say do as you're told and you do
they win
if you resist them and there's chaos and
fighting you're destroying the system
they win
it's what they want from the ashes of
the old they shall build anew it's what
they said during occupy wall street
i was told during occupy they said the
organizer said we want to flip the
pyramid over
and i said
how would that make sense
if you flip the pyramid over you have
one brick on the bottom no the pyramid
crumbles and forms
a crappy or crumbly pyramid and they're
like right and we're on the bottom now
and when you flip it over and the bricks
tumble down we'll be the ones on top
that was their view their view was not
to create a better world where the
working class were all equal and wealthy
it was that if you flip the pyramid over
some of the poor people will take
control and be in charge the rest is
going to fall down the side of the
pyramid the avalanche of rocks and get
crushed that's right we're definitely in
payback mode right this is
we're payback for what for who the
federal reserve the idea of how they've
been wronged and why
we are
so systematically
racist in this and fascist yes and so
when you if you're in payback mode
then you're not being rational and
you'll get these type of ideas and it
seems so fulfilling it again but it's so
emotionally based yeah people that are
willing to die for their cause are very
dangerous yes but these people also have
no sense of history they don't know what
happened in cuba or either that or
they're ignorant about it i was just so
funny i was just listening the other day
to an interview with andy garcia the
actor and i had no idea he was from cuba
and his family fled from there when he
was five and a half years old and the
interviewers asked him is just like so
what was that like you fled from cuba i
mean what was going on and the way that
he describes cuba that he fled from is
just like hair-raising he was just like
well you know the we we were told there
were gonna be public schools and the
revolution was gonna bring everybody
happiness and the public schools weren't
really schools they were just
indoctrination camps and all the
children you know there was no god and
they praised jay guevara and they
praised fidel and he's just like like
point by point laying out exactly what
happened even when he went back in the
90s and they he was just like i just
wanted to visit my homeland and they
turned it into this propaganda campaign
saying that i you know was supported the
revolution and it was just it was really
uh eye-opening hearing talk about that
when we're living in 2022. there's a
clip that the left likes to put around
uh push push out there where at the end
of the joe rogan podcast with twitter
the hot the mics stayed on
so joe is like all right everybody that
was great and he stands up and it shows
the rogan symbol and you can still hear
everything and vijayagaday of twitter
says i want to follow up on that antifa
account and i said it's bit.ly slash
antifa tweet or something like that
and then she says
you know what was this account or
whatever and i responded with i don't
want to give you information on
specifics that you can go and ban people
because i'm here
basically saying i don't think you
should be doing anything on my behest
they cut that part out and claim that
twitter colludes with the far right to
ban antifa and support fascists and
everything it is insane
how
people fall for this and believe it and
it's it's maddening and it's sad because
there are people who will hear that clip
and be like wow it must be true that's
it that's the combat mentality i was i
was talking to um a few uh good friends
of the show
and they mentioned dave rubin
saying something stupid they were like
oh but dave man he said that thing and i
was like what did he say and they're
like he said something about i can't
remember exactly what the quote was and
then i said wow you actually were
talking to him and he said this to you
they were like no but we saw it on
twitter and i was like
was he quoting someone else and they're
like i don't know it was a short clip
some activist posted and i was like so
why do you believe it
so so dave rubin could have been
quoting someone else and someone took a
clip of this and claimed he said it why
would you believe that
it's crazy that even people who are
aware of the tactics of the machine
still fall for it too yeah i definitely
um trained myself out of it with the
nick sandman thing when he got
confronted when he confronted got
confronted
i initially got angry and i was about to
yell out that was the first time i kind
of stopped and thought about maybe
there's something more to this
uh and then but it was like it wasn't
like one day i just stopped freaking out
about information i had to learn i'm
still to this day stuff will appear and
i'm like false flag remember false flag
remember keep your mind open yeah again
that's why i have no social platform
whatsoever
i say i just think
as far away from that as i can i mean
obviously it wasn't part of my
generation i having a cell phone so i
was 30. because they weren't around
right my first one i had was in belarus
and interestingly enough because it's
such a small country it was awesome
because they could put cell towers
around everywhere and it was really good
but so i didn't grow up with it it
wasn't part of it but i absolutely
detest
the fact that
you can get so inundated and so caught
up in it
that it
it's not profitable i try to be
profitable you know with my time and my
energy yeah i'll have such a good i'll
be in such a great state of mind i'll be
thinking about good stuff and then
sometimes i'll get on twitter and i'm
like
this stuff is so negative it's so niche
it's usually about like biden or like
about politics and it's just because i
follow a lot of people that come on the
show and that's what we talk about but
it's like so niche it's not like reality
as it is it's just a part of like the
game i gotta i gotta give you some
advice man triggering tim right look
look at look at who i fought you
couldn't go on twitter and pull my
account and look at who i follow and so
there's a good amount of activists
there's pundits there's left-wing and
right-wing pundits
and mostly news organizations what's
happening to a lot of people is that
they'll go on twitter and they'll follow
300 far left activists so their whole
world view is filtered by the far left
or they'll go on and follow 300
right-wing pundits and their whole world
view is filtered through right-wing
pundits
i i i use my twitter mostly as a tool
i post nonsense i often just you know
post things that like you know trigger
people or whatever you know i tweeted
today um was it today that uh putin was
scared of trump yeah boy to the left go
nuts on that one
and uh but mostly
who i'm following is like news sources
left and right some some are politically
active some aren't a lot of journalists
you'll you'll see in my following
account like some professors and some
journalists my world view is not crafted
by partisans it is it is i have i have a
a balanced you know because i want to
see what the left is saying sure no for
what you do it makes total sense right
but what we're getting is
journalists only follow the left
conservatives follow both
so you'll tend to see conservatives
understand the left the left doesn't
understand conservatives that's why the
democrats support trudeau and
independent voters republicans don't
probably because democrats don't watch
the news have no idea what he's done but
if you went to the average democrat
voter and said trudeau seized the bank
account of a single mother who works as
a waitress because when the when the
convoy was was first just driving on the
road she gave 50 bucks they'd be like
well that's crazy
but because they don't pay attention
they support
authoritarianism and therefore wouldn't
believe you right right
so this is what you know my friends are
telling me they're like they say like
good friends of mine from from back home
they say when i try telling my parents
they say it's a conspiracy theory
and then and they they're like you know
tim like you you've known him he used to
hang out here it's he's the one who's
talking about like ah he's wrong i watch
cnn
there's i met when i was in l.a i was
such a like a closet leftist i was just
blatantly like socialism yeah i didn't
know
and there's this mentality of like leave
me alone let me just live my life man i
want the government social services are
nice because if i need food stamps like
i'm with the actors and it's so
close-minded and oblivious to live like
that to think that what you have in
america is is like
the way things are like this is a result
of military conquest
it's not a joke and now there's problems
that are arising because of that
conquest also not a joke
so your luxury
is
tentative at best
get your mind in the game i need you
let's go to super chats if you have not
already you must i implore you honk that
like button give it a good hunk give it
a good smash a little thumbs up help
support the show subscribe to this
channel and share it with your friends
if you really do like it go over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only podcast coming up
around 11 or so p.m so you're not going
to want to miss that but most
importantly as a member you're helping
support all of our journalists who write
news every single day at timcast.com not
to mention the investigation we have
investigations into uh we have a book
coming out
ghosts of the civil war and looking for
the lost confederate gold
we're getting threats apparently
it's not even like a political it's not
even like political reporting but
our our uh uh our i i don't want to get
too much into it but
let's just say that people
who are who know about the lost
confederate gold are getting upset that
we've been digging into it
so after the civil war the confederates
you know shuffled off their gold so i
was thinking as kind of like a fun
adventure i didn't think it was going to
be so serious but dude someone
apparently died
anyway
support our work over timcats.com let's
read these super chats
all right let's see
the master of violence says ian
crossland is every member of the band
blind melon in the music video for no
rain
yeah what's up now do they all look like
you or something i think the lead singer
yeah they're all on here
yeah it's awesome awesome
all right let's see
joe harshbarger says steve please please
start a ranch in nebraska wide open
spaces in the land of the good life
absolutely listen we we'd love to build
10 15 more um
very expensive to do and this is why we
you know we're constantly
looking for investors especially if you
have a particular region in mind because
that so speeds up the process to be able
to do something like that like
franchising well i mean to still be part
of fortitude ranch but our texas one
exists because somebody
donated the land and had the ability to
help financially because
you know you've seen it out in west
virginia i mean it takes like a million
dollars to do it right yeah and so it
you know we're constantly it's part of
what i do as ceo reach out looking for
investors love to do it do you have any
plans for like um
community building
exercises and events or anything like
that yeah we have training coming up in
may um so this will be survival training
uh as we go through and and try to help
prepare our members we do want to do it
for non-members as well for those who
would looking uh would like to do that
for a fee
um
you know we just
we certainly want to to help our
you know our members specifically but we
do want to branch out and this is part
again like i was mentioning with with
survival housing with the counseling and
the ability to help with uh
with housing
solutions is we know we can't get not
everybody's going to be able to join
right but so if you're looking to do
something separately that's what we're
looking to help with i just i'm just
thinking how amazing it is it's going to
be like on a nice cool spring night you
know you're you're going throughout the
day you're learning all these important
survival skills but you're hanging out
you're having a good time oh and it
really is a great weekend we go out to
eat right so it starts on a saturday at
eight o'clock
we we have some
some summer powerpoint right to give you
the instruction for the things you're
going out to do like if you're going to
train at the ranch uh on the firing
range yeah firing range right and then
we do land navigation
show you how to we we read maps we fired
uh barrett m82
over at the ranch 50 bmg
yeah that was so fun it was it wasn't as
bad as i thought it was going to be
but it was amazing that you guys hit
something because you didn't have a
scope right yeah no we had iron sights
right well but not i mean
that's not easy to do that's all i'm
saying well so uh if if you know for
those that are interested you know
survival training community building
hanging out with like-minded people and
learning some skills that sounds pretty
fun man so yeah maybe maybe you guys
will get some uh we'll get more up and
running let's read some more super chats
all right
neo jade says tim you don't believe it's
possible that cabal is running things
what do you need a times article
detailing exactly that ian matched it
all the chat when ian said that was like
20s
but i'll clarify what i mean is you know
i don't think that biden
walks into the great hall on some island
with all these other leaders and then
they're like they've got pictures of
epstein on the wall and they're just
like you know klaus schwab walks in and
says now you will all do as you are told
haha i think birds of a feather flock
together i think all of these world
leaders meet in davos they meet the
you know at the un or the g7 the g20
they all think similarly they all hang
out with each other it's like if you go
to a skate park and you see 10
skateboarders all from different parts
of the city they're going to be speaking
the same language using the same jargon
and wanting the same things it doesn't
mean it's organized it just means that
they've
effectively formed that
that's what i mean they all know that if
it happens in your country it can happen
in my country so they're like
authoritative what i mean is like
you know there's a skateboarder from the
north side a skateboarder from the south
side a skateboarder from the east and
west sides and they're all at one skate
park they're saying the same words yo
dude just did a nollie flip crook big
spin out it was sick and they all know
what it means
better bro exactly they're all saying
the same thing because when they go
drink so so there's something called the
journo list it was where journalists
were on message boards private message
boards with each other in new york so
what would happen is one journalist
would post a story they'd all see it and
then all of a sudden every outlet would
publish the same story it wasn't because
there was a cabal intentionally trying
to control things it was because
journalists were like i'd like to hang
out with germany in this situation
that's naturally immoral it was an
emergent phenomenon i believe there's a
cabal that is literally trying to
control things just so just so
everyone's clear
no i certainly think that's uh they're
succeeding or not but it seems like they
are i think trying to the davos group
wants to control things
i think but but i don't think like when
biden said build back better and when i
heard those words come out of his mouth
i was like okay it's been it's been
co-opted but boris johnson accused him
of stealing it
what the and biden's a plagiarist oh
yeah so it's it's what if he stole it he
did from the from the world economic
yeah
right we he apologized for drums yeah he
had to drop out of the 1988 presidential
election because he got caught
plagiarizing so the simple solution is
that biden is a plagiarist it was 88.
and in europe in the eu they all use the
same look i i absolutely think klaus
schwab has plans i absolutely think he's
publicly stated he wants to get people
in these cabinets i think he is a
dangerous evil individual
i'm just saying
i don't imagine that biden calls up
klaus schwab and says what's the plan
you know what i mean yeah i think they
just all hang out and all share the same
ideas and then act accordingly
so it makes more sense oligarchy as
opposed to a top down from klaus
all right rob matt says do you plan on
making a timcast.com app i'd like to
stop using my browser to watch the after
show podcast yes
um we are it's currently being made it's
being made right now and um for those
that are wondering if you use brave the
brave browser you can actually listen to
the podcast while your screen is off
because um i think i'm pretty sure brave
allows that
all right let's get some more of these
super chats
foul says i have many friends in ukraine
i wish them much love seriously
ukraine's amazing man there was actually
a period where i was like i wonder if i
could live there because it's so cheap
for an american to live there
inexpensive inexpensive it's a better
way to put it
and um people who have foreign revenue
who live there they live they live very
very well so they're they're ukrainians
who get jobs as programmers and make six
figures u.s
in a country where you only need you
know a thousand bucks a month
you know to to get lunch and to pay for
rent and everything like that so
they live very very well relatively
cortos quarter maltese says tim why do
you say the u.s versus russia uss versus
china you do know that the entirety of
europe would oppose russia and taiwan
and japan and india would oppose china
right the world could defend itself
without the us i hear you yep absolutely
i just think as an american seeing joe
biden say these things it's what the u.s
is in conflict with i certainly think
other countries would have conflict as
well which is why we talk about world
war three
jason says i received the go truck
yourself shirt love it go tim and castle
crew hong kong nice yeah we have a shirt
over at timcast.com says go truck
yourself
go truck yourself to dc
all right
the happy holistic says did you hear
putin's speech he said they only want
that part of ukraine that was russia's
as a buffer against nato the communists
gave it away and he rebuked communism
while the west has embraced it
wow did he really say that
dude that's bold wow
well i mean in that capacity i don't
know if he's wrong
i used to think like i was just
terrified i was like oh he's a dictator
he's evil but in a way i think that he's
holding on to russia so that some psycho
doesn't take control and then go full
woke he's like the last vestige of
freedom on earth is it could that even
be possible that it was putin all along
red white and blue
all right captain says ian the us had b1
and b2 aircraft china and russia have
been trying to replicate the
capabilities of them for decades now
b-52 are for dropping fun police on
dudes on horseback that have no anti-air
iran's got a lot of anti-air though but
um
i think i think people need to
realize when it comes to war
we got bombs we got people we got
technology but they've got cyber
capabilities china and russia and
they've got propaganda capabilities the
future of warfare
if you've got all the nukes in the world
but your country is crippled by civil
conflict you can't fire them they may as
well be useless
you may as well not have yeah and i mean
russia has
you know not the same quantities as far
as
uh what we have in the best of the
equipment but they have awesome you know
air defense they got hypersonic missiles
now at this point i mean they're no
slouch don't get me wrong i looked i
think china has about 500 nuclear
warheads and that they're expected to
have a thousand of them in 10 years
that's right that was big news that
china was um rapidly building new uh
silence yep
well
of course you know
all right
excited says tim gets mad at ian for
talking about mixing household items tim
also gives a rundown on taking down
power plants i didn't say how
they were taken down i said ten years
ago there was a a flaw publicly
disclosed
all right
i love you guys all right michael adkins
says attention that's right
says uh michael aiken says clinton grad
was part of germany where emmanuel kant
was born is that true yeah how how did
it come to be his little pocket exists
because when
the end of world war ii when everybody
was dividing everything up they made
sure that russia yeah very smart they
wanted access to the baltic sea
absolutely man they planned ahead yeah
russia doing russia stuff man
mr physics says here's the messed up
part guys putin is 100 correct all of
the baltics besides poland and lithuania
from like 860 to 1991
the cleveland line was destroyed by the
mongols and gave rise to muscovy
all the baltics what were russia i know
that uh kiev was the capital of russia
what in like 1080 or something about how
how far you want to go back right
exactly to the cavemen
there's the original lines of
demarcation i mean
you know right yeah the ruse princess
took this land from someone else yeah
yep
let's see we got here
john says john hutto says odessa is
heavily russian and moldova is very
sympathetic could he create a new
moldova inside russia
what do you think
i mean it's possible again
they
don't underestimate the effects of the
rustification and
how people feel a connection in uh you
know certain parts of what used to be
the former soviet union uh speaking of
moldova i have a piece of moldovite
that's a little off cool topic this is a
volcanic glass or no this is from an
asteroid impact and then it creates this
green glass found in moldova i think
it's found
cucumber says biden says he can tolerate
just the tip
i don't believe him
well prove it there you go
micah says tim i think the police in
canada are being controlled by an
inhibitor chip like the clones on star
wars just a thought that's the only way
to explain it right when they stood
they're all silent no uh there's leaked
messages where they're laughing about
trampling on with their horses
like an old lady was on a mobility
scooter and they trampled over on a
horse and they're gloating and laughing
about the injuries
i i i will say
conservatives are getting a cold splash
of water in the face on this one
with these cops just brutalizing
conservatives they've been doing it now
for some times the moment conservatives
start protesting like wait a minute the
cops are beating us we're the ones who
supported them so yeah they don't care
the royal police man yeah that's why
look
um i remember when attila's jim
was getting shut down and the cops were
there and the guys that tell us jim like
we're gonna have them on but they were
saying uh uh don't blame the cops
they're doing their job and i'm like
what
those cops don't gotta come and shut you
down they could leave
the the first cops from the from that
town did they were like yeah have a nice
day
then then they pulled in cops from other
cities who came in and said we don't
live here and we don't care and brought
the boot to people's necks there was a
uh counterpoint to what's going on in
canada there was this one trucker on the
daily mail he said uh they were as dumb
as a bag of hammers they acted like
keystone cops
truckers number 53 dumber than a bag of
hammers salted hammers keystone cop
keystone
exactly there were these old like
black and white reels of the cops that
were like really stupid
yeah i just watched a really interesting
documentary which i found out some it
was really uh worth watching oh keystone
film company 1912-1917
yeah it all has that charlie chaplin was
it was amazing story but that's where
that comes from anyway point being this
one guy said that the cops are too
stupid to be able to do their job right
at least the ones that arrested him and
zip tied him in five degree weather for
30 minutes wow
all right alex jones was right says
tim you've said before social media
tends to become right wing and now the
world seems to be coming right wing
thanks to the internet in what uh in
what some call the great awakening could
this be the reason for the great reset
no i don't think so i think the great
reset is very specific plan by powerful
international elites
and like klaus schwab he just comes out
and says all this stuff so you know the
world economic forum
davos group they've got plans there but
i do think the expansion of the internet
has allowed
meritocracy
to rapidly expand if you look at what
this show is
when this show started when i started
working on youtube even before this show
nobody gave me money nobody came to me
and said here's here's an investment and
here's access to advertisement i just
started youtube channel and started
making content i did better and better
people liked it they shared it organic
growth there was zero advertising
involved in any of this no zero
marketing it was just organic growth
based on
what we put together and constantly
improving and doing a better job and
journalists right now though
they'll get out of college they'll have
no skills they'll apply and be hired by
nbc news which has an existing platform
and be given a megaphone there's no
meritocracy the reason i think the
internet makes things more right-wing is
because meritocracy is it ends up
flourishing
due to it before before the internet if
you wanted access you'd get a job at a
you had to go through a gatekeeper but
you also had to speak their language
like i was locked out of hollywood
because i wouldn't bow and you were
locked out of univision i think it's
univision right they just
hired me they golden handcuffed you one
of those companies disney
the first the first six months they were
like you're doing great and then as soon
as they decided to get woke i said no
yeah they went okay real merit can't
function in weird corporate autocracy
where it's all about speak party line
like merit
emerges independently i had a really
good idea for a video game that i
pitched to vice and to abc
because they were like we'd be
interested in pursuing you know
production and the idea was to do a um
an online game
where once a week an apocalyptic
scenario happens oh i would love to i
was just playing seven days to die last
night i would love to use something like
this so here's the idea
you play the game monday through
thursday you collect items you run
around you do whatever or you don't
friday around 7pm an apocalyptic
scenario happens an alien invasion a
flood volcanic eruption zombie
apocalypse military dictatorship and
then the goal is survive the weekend or
you know survive the scenario maybe it
would only be for like three hours
and then data would process the next day
sunday they would release here's how
people responded to the crisis so if it
was like an alien invasion it would be
like 73 percent of players hid in the
basement three percent of players went
on rampages you know one percent
peacefully walked up to the aliens if
it's a zombie apocalypse it would like
break down
here's how we analyzed player behavior
when this scenario was presented to them
so it's like
it would just be an open world game kind
of like a gta
until the scenario every friday night or
maybe it's sunday night would be better
monday morning what's good news no
people are working good for news yeah
monday morning
we could release the data that was the
plan and um
they i mean they were all like wow these
are these are great i think if uh maybe
it's a game we'll make now that we have
the ability to do so but in the company
they have no obligation to make a game
they have no experience in making and a
lot of people they were like it's a good
idea we'll explore this but what you
were saying about meritocracy not
working there it doesn't work there
because
they're they're all following a path
they're all told
do task a b c d
what i propose deviates from that path
so they ignore it never and it doesn't
happen you know i told vice and fusion
i said to vice in 2013
all of your personalities should have
youtube channels yes you should hire
producers for them who film them at
their desks talking about the news
stories and what they're passionate
about and they were like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're not gonna do that
and imagine how big it would have been
we're a huge dude i mean look what we're
doing i told fusion the same thing and
they were fusion actually said give it a
shot see what you can do and i said sure
and it worked i mean it worked
moderately well i was producing stuff
for my own channel but it wasn't exactly
what uh what i pitched
it could have been it could have been so
big for them and now look at all these
big youtubers
they're not the journalists they could
listen to me they didn't want to that
disaster game is awesome man it could be
a good analytic learning tool of human
psychology if it's like a freeze yeah
you could do you could do covid as long
as friday night all of a sudden everyone
gets a respiratory disease and start
dropping dead if it's a proprietary game
that might suck because facebook gets
the data yeah yeah make it like a human
learning tool we we the idea was to
create a base game that was open to
community modification through some kind
of democratic process and we would need
the assistance of the community for
planning and preparing scenarios so
there could be like cool scripted events
where like at 7 pm all of a sudden in
the game sirens go off and then all the
tvs and all of the video game
storefronts turn on it's like the
president trump or biden or whoever and
they're like martial law lockdown's
happening now and then you see troops
being deployed all throughout the cities
and how do you play that game what do
you do
if the goal is to survive right and then
if you win you get a bonus or something
crazy dude does that mean fun gamer
candle i wonder what people would do
cannibalism in the video game because
it's a video game
yeah you need food and stuff we were
like you'd have to survive so like you
need it it'd only be for a few hours but
like the great flood would be funny
because people who are on the ground
running around and driving around with
their basement they're like my basement
is fully stocked and people would be
like i'm gonna hide in my my house and
then also it fills with water and you
lose and the people who are on
skyscrapers got lucky and it would just
be like 83 of players were on the ground
and died and you'd be like oh come on
some people would be in boats you know
that's that's one idea anyway we should
we should read some more of these
patrick c said ian is rolling double 20s
all night double deuce yeah let me just
shout out this
awesome 20-sided die again just received
today
from very very amazing with it
and yes you are right sir thank you very
much
all right
we had a good one i just missed it where
did it go
buck erst buck rust says first time
super chat resident resident of
frederick maryland during the mandate we
never complied grocery store was fine no
one bothered us but five below toy store
called the police what wow that's weird
five below
cops the mandate was in fact like a
month
it was the most weird it was the
weirdest thing they were like we're
doing a mandate and then i guess when no
one listened they were like we're not
going to do the mandate anymore yeah
literally on the first day they brought
it back i went to barnes noble and we
were like we're not going to wear a mask
we're going to see if anyone says
anything no one said a thing the whole
time this mandate was back that's insane
that that store called the police that's
wild frankie sharad says tim how is the
new baby chick it was awesome to see
that on cast castle if you go to
youtube.com cast castle we we have a
video of one of a baby chick hatching in
fact two hatched two the other one came
out yeah i was giving it love last night
it came out i went down at two in the
morning sending love and health and come
i'm you're i'm here with you totally
healthy popped out happy happy as can be
and now we got 22 more eggs in the
incubator
we are rapidly expanding this year
chicken city all right
all right joe masonic says i noticed tim
started building on ian's comments
recently it's definitely a plus four to
ian's dice rolling and makes the show
better keep up the good work everyone
well i got to be honest it's because ian
is rolling more twenties
ian rolls a one i'm gonna be like no no
no that's why tim's in my party because
he's honest
no ian's been rolling some 20s i mean
even people people were saying i was the
one who rolled the one when you said the
cabal was controlling the planet
that's a good conversation
they were like tim you're wrong there is
a ball i'm like all right all right
all right everybody
all right let's just uh we'll grab some
more super chats here
brian
wisecarver says i'm at the beginning of
the people's convoy coordinating
incoming donations in california we're
leaving tomorrow i've emailed pitches at
timcast.com uh to communicate with you
guys
send an email to spin the ufo at
gmail.com if you could can you look for
that i will and that's uh brian
wisecarver and then we're trying to
coordinate some kind of uh coverage of
the of the us convoy check in right now
says have you looked into local building
codes for constructing earth ships and
passive housing in the survival housing
communities
yeah one of the things we actually try
to do is uh build in areas that have uh
less of the bureaucratic
uh part of things as far as you know
like out in west virginia there is no
building code so i mean obviously we
stick to standard you know measures for
safety of everybody involved through the
things that we built but
when you're talking survival though you
know it's all about location location
location so you don't have to have
necessarily an underground bunker if
you're where you have
your location has a good defensible you
know area
this is a good one garhant says how are
you going to prevent sectarian violence
in the ranch it's not impossible for
biden collapsing the world and how many
members will have biden bumper stickers
might want blue red ranches no actu so
what happens is this this kind of
happens organically
i couldn't really choose a better you
know i don't know every member in all
the other locations but in west virginia
it's an amazing combination of folks now
we don't vet we don't ask you what your
political affiliation is anything like
that but people who tend to gravitate
towards wanting to be a member
they tend to be of like-mindedness
and so we really don't have
that as a major situation but one of the
key things is i try to spend as much
time as i can getting to know the
members allow them to get to know me and
a key to
why some of these who try to do it on
their own it falls apart because there
is no leadership where there's clear
lines of leadership you know at every uh
ranch that's why we only hire former law
enforcement or military and by the way
we're looking to hire uh again since
we've expanded so what roles as ranch
manager or and we have a position for
assistant ranch manager and so if people
want to reach out to
fortitudityranch.com and uh reach out to
manager fortitudityranch.com we'll be
collecting those resumes and reaching
out to folks cool
right on right on cool man well how
about this everybody head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have that member segment coming up
uh as a member you're supporting all of
our journalists and we greatly
appreciate it it's how we fund the
operation it's our principal source of
of funding the memberships from our
website so we're going to get to
recording that special segment for all
of you guys so don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
you can follow us on instagram at tim
cast irl where we post clips you can
follow our tim cast clips channel for
shorter couple minute segments that's on
youtube
you can follow me at tim cast basically
anywhere uh steve you want to mention
anything more specifically
i do uh want to mention about survival
housing since this is the new startup um
so you can find us at
survivalhousing.net
and
if you have our initial consultation is
always free we're trying to reach out
and help folks since we're not at every
location across the country there's a
lot of things right in the very
beginning that you can make mistakes on
and we're trying to help folks avoid
that
i'm working with a
a group prepper broadcasting network
to bring in some of their consultants as
well because there's certain expertise
uh we could all join forces with uh
james walton's doing an excellent job
they have 15
podcasts 11 that are live every day and
you can get great uh survival type
information off them so we're we're
combining forces because
i don't see any way out of this and i'm
not a fear monger but people are going
to need to have need a plan and
you really should be reaching out and
looking to better your position
absolutely
go man what's the what's the website for
for either of them did you mention those
uh so it's prepper
broadcastingnetwork.com
and then for
survivalhousing.net so if you if you
want to get even just the free consult
then you can just fill out the con
contact form and we'll get back with you
and then there's also a fortitude ranch
and then.com yep so we work hand in hand
i'm ceo of both of them so at fortitude
ranch then you can reach out there for
more information if you want to become a
member uh those who would be looking to
want uh
you know a ranch built in a different
area that we know don't have right now
please understand it takes investors in
order to crank open a new one and so
we're definitely looking to do that as
well the best part about fortitude ranch
is the dog that licks rocks yes ringo
rico
i'm not joking
he grabs a big rock makes sure you're
looking at him and then just puts his
tongue on it and sits there yeah it's
the it's the mineralization oh yeah they
got into skunks about three days ago oh
yeah yeah i gotta i gotta wash them oh
man all right awesome uh chriscar17 on
twitter check out timcast.com uh anytime
you like but especially tomorrow because
we've got a really nice report coming
out from michael robison our writer a
potential supreme court case that could
have some major impacts on first
amendment rights michael robinson also
with the monkeys that watch the show
shout out to michael and the monkeys
those monkeys are awesome got a picture
of the monkey like really keyed into
what we were talking about on the
monkeys man yeah i love those monkeys uh
i'm ian crossland fall media
crossland.net thank you guys so much for
coming and i'll see you later and before
we go i wanted to say that i do have to
agree with tim this is not a cabal the
definition of a cabal is a secret
political click or faction this is not a
secret so what's going on with the
elites is definitely not a cabal i'm
sarah patrick's you can follow me on
twitter and at mines.com
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for that member segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you